what's debt ceiling talks ongoing it
seems like the u.s. may see yet another
increase in the debt ceiling the u.s. is
one of the wealthiest countries in the
world with the GDP of nineteen point
three nine trillion dollars and a GDP
per capita of over fifty nine thousand
dollars which is the seventh highest in
the world but the u.s. also has a lot of
debt more specifically over twenty two
trillion dollars in debt while this is a
large number what actually matters is
the debt to GDP ratio currently this
ratio is at 105 point eight nine percent
and we're constantly increasing debt
ceilings the US must whare money and
default on loans at one point right well
as president Trump often declares the US
will never have to default on a loan
payment as that Federal Reserve can
simply print more money but this is
clearly not a long-term solution and
we'll end up doing more harm than good
right well this will no doubt lead to
hyperinflation and leave the US and
shambo's like Germany after World War
one or is in Bob way with hundred
trillion dollar bills that are worthless
so while the US government could resort
to printing money here and there this
would not be sustainable then why does
it seem like the government doesn't
really care at all about the
skyrocketing debt that is literally
increasing by the trillions every single
year well to answer this we have to take
a look at what would unfold as a
government paid off the debt to do this
the clear and most obvious choice is to
cut costs and create a surplus but this
is not as easy as it sounds and there
will be a lot of negative repercussions
first off the US government has three
portions mandatory spending this
questionary spending and interest on
federal debt stopping interest payments
would be the same thing as defaulting on
a loan so we can't do anything about
this one but it seems simple just our
discretionary spending right well
discretionary spending is actually not
so discretionary as they include things
like the military in education while the
government definitely does not need to
be spending over 700 billion
the military the military is no doubt
very important for national security
though there are places in the military
that you could cut spending like in the
oshio or overseas contingencies
operations it would make most sense for
the u.s. to save on the military by
stopping International Affairs like
conflicts the Islamic state group and
removing a twenty four thousand American
soldiers from South Korea this will
ensure that the message security is not
compromised and could save the u.s.
upwards of two hundred billion dollars
per year but there would be
international consequences the reach of
the Islamic state group will no doubt
expand and we will see an increase in
acts of terrorism as for North Korea
this may be the perfect opportunity for
them to launch an attack toward South
Korea and while South Korea has the
seventh strongest military in the world
North Korea is no pushover having the
eighteenth strongest this could easily
escalate into a global conflict where
Russia and China would support North
Korea and at this point South Korea
would require help from the US and other
Western allies and this would actually
end up backfiring and increase the u.s.
debt even more so the US would have to
be very careful when reducing military
spending moreover discretionary spending
wouldn't be enough to cover the national
deficit of 1.03 chilean dollars anyways
so the US would have to dip into
mandatory spending as this makes up the
biggest proportion of the u.s. budget
occupying almost two-thirds of it most
of this is made up of Social Security
and Medicare out of 2015 Medicare cost
nine hundred and eighty six billion and
Social Security cost eight hundred
ninety five billion while very expensive
these are services that the US
government owes its citizens as these
programs are funded by taking cuts from
US residents payroll if the US
government were to prioritize paying
back its loans it would have to reduce
social security and medicare spending
but what about income taxes couldn't the
government simply increase income taxes
to pay off the debt the answer is no
because this increase would simply be
too much the US federal tax revenues
three point four trillion dollars and
considering the one trillion dollar
deficit all tax not just income tax
would have increased by 30 percent to
cover the difference
imagine paying thirty two percent tax on
your house and thirty
percent tax on a new car okay all right
but while a small increase like 5% just
on income tax to supplement reduce
spending
well this 5% increase would be basically
nothing for the US government but a
significant increase in taxes for US
residents and this would lead to an
additional decrease in GDP GDP is
calculated by summing together
government spending consumer spending in
investments and exports and subtracting
import from all of that the US GDP is
already going to decrease from reduced
government spending and the last thing
they would want to do is accelerate this
decrease by increasing income tax which
would reduce consumer spending so
considering all of the options the most
plausible idea would be to carefully
reduce spending in the military and get
most of the capital from Medicare and
Social Security starting off with Social
Security these checks are actually not
very much averaging just fourteen
hundred dollars a month and just a
little over $17,000 per year which is
basically minimum wage while not much
considering Americans abysmal savings
many retirees rely on these checks for
day to day life if this check was
significantly reduced like cut in half
Americans will hold on her jaw from much
longer and delay retirement into her 70s
or 80s or simply die working this would
make it significantly harder for fresh
college graduates and less experienced
workers to get a job as coverage with no
doubt prefer more seasoned employees
this would increase unemployment across
the US as well as increased government
spending on unemployment benefits as
from Medicare twenty point four million
beneficiaries would be directly impacted
by reduced spending in Medicare
considering that Medicare is for the
elderly a lot of coverages for
prescription drugs that people rely on
such as insulin to reduce Medicare
spending the US government would have to
start charging monthly premiums on all
of their plans reduced coverage and/or
increased a deductible all of this would
again discourage people from retiring
but on top of this we would most likely
see major public backlash against these
new policies US citizens will no doubt
feel cheated out of their money and we
will see protests and movements to which
the US government will again have spent
money to control people will start to
become resistant and paying for these
programs as they
no longer see a benefit in paying for
them people will demand that these
programs be abolished as there are no
long been efficient the public or at the
very least demand for decrease in the
amount that they are charged every month
for them hopefully oh by this point the
US will be able to better distribute the
debt burden on two more categories and
be able deliver a decrease in Social
Security and Medicare costs so finally
the national debt and backlash will
mostly be controlled but what about the
US economy unemployment will soar in
consumer spending most all and a US GDP
will plummet not only will people not be
able to find a job due to a reduced in
retirement but people will be displaced
from government-sponsored jobs like
building roads and government buildings
the u.s. will no doubt enter another
economic recession like in 2008 but
there will be a couple of key
differences while there may be an
increase in loan defaults US financial
institutions will be much stronger than
they were in 2008 and definitely not be
filling in the masses and with the
Federal Reserve not just printing
billions of dollars to pay off loans the
US currency would hold exponentially
more value and only be hurt by the
decrease in GDP there would be
international repercussions as well
especially for China as Chinese exports
the u.s. was significantly decrease
eventually however let's assume things
would sell down and the US government
will no longer be running at a deficit
but even at this point something to
consider is that it would take several
decades for them to finish paying off
all of the debt there would be a couple
of positives though while consumer
spending will decrease it hurt the GDP
initially this means that people are
saving more money for retirement and
becoming less dependent on government
provided services and eventually the US
economy will recover and become stronger
than ever before while this sounds
really good this would be nowhere close
to economy that could have blossomed
with the help of debt as debt isn't a
bad thing all the big companies and
richest people in the world have a debt
for a reason it's because it helps
foster growth and development it helps
them leverage their money and create
even more value take a look at Apple the
most valid company in the world who has
a hundred billion dollars in long-term
debt yet they have over two hundred
fifty billion dollars in cash rose
so if they wanted to they could pay this
off right now in one payment but Apple
would prefer to use his cash and
acquisitions or development of new
products based in the end that will be
more productive than just paying off the
debt this is the same reason that
wealthy people don't buy expensive
properties in cash while I had to pay
interest to the bank usually they are
able to get really low interest rates
usually under 4% and using that money
they didn't pour into her property they
are able to produce returns that equate
to around 10% per year stable to profit
the difference
considering this why should things be
any different for the government
investing into the country instead of
paying off debt will create so much more
value in the long term for example let's
say the u.s. bard might to improve
infrastructure this would create
thousands of jobs which would reduce
unemployment and encourage consumer
spending when people are buying more
products like iPhones companies like
Apple make more money which leads to
them hiring more employees and improving
their products even more and guess what
Apple along with ODS
employees will increase income tax
revenue for the US government probably
far more than money they spent on
improving the infrastructure in the
first place and increase the US GDP as
well and not only that but these new
employees will go home with more money
to spend
sure a lot of them will spend it on
themselves but there will be a select
few that will start another business
that will again not only grow the US tax
revenue but also go to US GDP and if the
US GDP is significantly increasing then
the increase in debt doesn't matter just
think about it this way if you make more
money you can take on a larger mortgage
and live a better lifestyle but to make
more money you need to invest in
yourself whether that's learning a trade
and growing a plumbing business or
taking on student loan debt well a
student loan may seem like a burden with
the degree in the right subject you can
expect to make a nice income and easily
pay it off in other words the student
loan is more of an investment than a
burden but there are so many people
struggling with student loans and this
principle also applies to the US
government as well as for these torrents
that loan was not a worthwhile
investment this same thing could be said
about the u.s. for things like
overspending on military which won't
provide much
return and simply burn other sectors
debt is very good for growth but can
also be very dangerous and needs to be
handled correctly but this is why the
quantity of US debt doesn't matter it's
the way that bard money is spent for
instance if you continuously took three
hundred thousand dollar loans and spent
it on properties that increase your
value and produce rental income while
some of them may not pay back as long as
most of them pay back you will be fine
same thing applies for the government
the government can have a hundred
trillion dollars in debt but it wouldn't
matter at all if the US GDP was a
hundred trillion so the u.s. just needs
to be careful and ensure that debt
doesn't grow faster than GDP because
that is when one ends up in a position
like Japan or Greece which is obviously
not good right now the debt is going
faster than GDP so this is definitely
something that needs to be controlled
very quickly but overall as the u.s. is
a growing country increasing debt is
nothing to worry about as it can lead
the growth of unimaginable scales if
under the right management and this is
why paying up debt is not a priority but
rather ensuring that the value created
using debt or in other words the
increase in real GDP is equal to or
greater than a debt taken on and as long
as that holds true debt ceilings can
continuously be increased and they use
government nor you need to be worried
but that's how hard for you guys are why
the federal government doesn't care
about the skyrocketing national debt if
you guys like this video they may drop a
like and consider subscribing if so I
see more videos just like this one but
until then I'm hari
I'll see you guys on next one
you